on the fourth and final day of climate
protests in Westminster The Beat Goes On
campaigners demanding an end to new oil
and gas drilling even though they know
the government is doing the opposite
what these people in this building need
to know is that this is not going away
you know the climate impacts are
exponential they're Rising day by day
and so are we
[Music]
the threat from activists is that if
they are ignored the relative peace and
Order of these protests will soon be
replaced by something else
we're going to really have to think
about our strategies going forwards
right I mean the whole point of doing
these protests is to try and make a
change I think Civil Disobedience will
definitely be part of it
the just stop oil group is already
committed to more of these rolling
roadblocks in London and Beyond
but whatever happens in the coming weeks
sisters are unlikely to shift course
making clear they won't respond to
demands issued in this way and defending
their record on decarbonization despite
these protests the government argues it
is making progress particularly when it
comes to clean power generation and
especially in offshore winds
at the North Sea Summit in Belgium today
for example the UK and other European
nations announced new interconnectors to
share electricity and committed to a
significant expansion of offshore Wind
by 2050. the power of that win the
ability for that to create megawatts
gigawatts of electricity for Europe is
singly good news and is one of the
things which brings us together it isn't
enough for the protesters in London they
point to failures on home insulation
transport and land use all of these
things must be fixed they say if the UK
is to keep its promise to limit global
warming Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in
Westminster